nouveau confinement rime avec nouvelle
fermeture alors que seuls les magasins
de première nécessité resteront ouverts
durant ces quatre semaines
cette mise sous cloche est perçue comme
un véritable coup de massue pour les
autres ces commerçants contraints de
fermer leurs boutiques pour la troisième
fois en un an sont découragés façon que
si vous voulez qu'on dise même si on
râle ça va râler dans le vent on est
obligé de subir mais après moi je trouve
qu'on paye pour les gens qui font pas
attention tout simplement je pense que
si on avait son faisait tous attention
on n'en serait peut-être pas là sans ce
moment ben j'ai pas envie de me plaindre
parce que ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
voilà et c'est compliqué pour tout le
monde et pour eux aussi donc pour est
désolant c'est regrettable mais on n'y
peut rien certains prétendent que l'état
manque de considération envers leur
profession ils se sentent abandonnés et
réclament plus de solutions on va
surtout aussi que falloir que l'état
comme le premier ministre nous l'a
indiqué début de semaine que l'état
trouve des solutions pour nous les
commerces qui sont fermés notamment le
prêt-à-porter le prêt-à-porter
on a vraiment l'impression d'être les
grands oubliés de cette crise sanitaire
par rapport aux aides outre
l'impossibilité d'accéder à ces
commerces dits non essentiels les
nouvelles règles de circulation sont
parfois jugés contradictoires et
contestable
certains habitants concernés par le
confinement n'hésite pas à faire part de
leur lassitude
tout le monde reste un peu dans la
compréhension sa confinement qui on
n'est pas vraiment à et tout le monde
sera en courte qu'on préférerait
peut-être finalement être vraiment
confiné pour essayer de vraiment passé
ce virus mais là on a l'impression qu'on
cherche à tourner un peu autour du pot
pour faire quelque chose qui a beaucoup
de gens qui vont souffrir notamment en
vrai les commerçants c'est ça en fait
c'est qu'on se dit que finalement le
virus circule surtout finalement à
l'école et au boulot etc les deux seuls
endroits où
les gens ont le droit d'aller donc c'est
que c'est très contradictoires qu'on n'a
pas le moral vraiment on a pu rien pour
eux c'est vivre pour manger dormir est
cloîtrée c'est comme une prison
les 16 régions confiné dès ce week-end
représente 21 millions d'habitants dont
12 millions en région parisienne des
mesures décrétées pour au moins quatre
semaines est susceptible d'être étendue
selon l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire